[Music]
do you guys have your venmo account
password protected mm-hmm like when you
open the app you have to put in your
password mm-hmm every time you open my
password or that yeah
no mines my passwords my face
let me check like can I mother why did
it get hat did it someone this woman she
actually got scammed
like hey I don't like please tell me
what happened
well the way actually I will let her
tell you what happened it's a video
video um no she that's North Carolina to
Brittany someone asked about her phones
it's not corona them it's Fox 46
terrible I was virtually inconsolable is
like my phone died I need to get this
pin for my girlfriend because someone's
stealing packages off of our porch but I
can't remember the pen so I called this
woman on my bluetooth speaker so he
could just lean in through the card and
they just exchanged about sentences he
said okay she's gonna text you do you
mind if I have your phone so it was like
I have these three phones that I'm
shipping to my daughter's hold on to
these three phones while I have your
phone and so I can just shoot this real
quick text and I was just thinking okay
that sounds about right
he can't get to me and he can't really
steal my phone because I have his three
phone in about 10 seconds he had been
bowed himself 2,300 dollars out of my
account because there was no password
protected why it kind of got my mind
going a little bit was one of the phones
went off when he said the venmo because
he got the notification that I had sent
the money and that's when I was like
okay wait a minute one of your phones is
working but before I could really even
say something he was handing my phone
back and stupidly I was handing him the
three phones since that was he was gone
what does this agreement how this get
set up but so this is that number
iPad demo had a two thousand dollar
block oh yeah that's three if there's a
creepy guy that ever hits
you say oh why would you even pass your
phone to someone you can tell me he gave
her three phones so she could feel like
well he has lateral yeah I slapped him
on the ground and said I don't give a
[ __ ] about your Nokia [ __ ]
why was she bar with a tiny phones
because why okay because he was saying
that he needed to contact his wife
okay as an emergency so she calls the
wife that's why I like she was able he
was able to still speak to her through
the window why you don't help people you
just [ __ ] go Bluetooth in your car
but then he tells her oh I need a shoot
a text can I borrow your phone here you
get my three phones so you know I'm not
gonna steal your phone
that's pretty genius I read this one
words like if a creepy guy hits on you
like if he's being a [ __ ] scumbags
big oh yeah I'll give you my number give
me your phone
grabbed someone who's been more yourself
and he's gifted he did what if he did
that painted [ __ ] what if you did that
and it was like insufficient funds and
he's like he feels so bad and he puts
money in your venmo
did she have a password on her gun well
that's exactly what she said I don't
think I have a patent on airplane mode
man turned off to find out I'm just
saying if it has to do with money you
have Wi-Fi on is just opening the app
and immediately I'll ask you for a
passenger ya know if [ __ ] why would you
not have a password thing on anything
that has to do with money well because
of the story I put a password on my
phone stranger touch your phone no I'd
have been like tell me what you wanted
text I'll text it for you that's it
did I tell you guys about the time a
stranger stole my phone yeah dude stole
your phone he's like walked away so I
was jogging at this track right and then
Justin was shooting me jogging and I
left my phone on the grass and then I'm
me and Justin are the only ones is
[ __ ] like 7 a.m. in the morning we're
done shooting and I go
where the [ __ ] is my phone I'm looking
in the grass and I'm like oh [ __ ] it's
like when you lose something like like a
haystack haystack right so we're like
going up and down like oh this one I
left my [ __ ] phone here what the hell
is going on and then I let me do Find My
iPhone on your phone so I Justin's phone
I'm looking at it my phone and it goes
oh wait my phone's over there next to
the park bathrooms how the [ __ ] over
there I'd even pee over there so we go
over there and then I'm gonna go over
there and we refresh it it's now on the
street we're like what the [ __ ] someone
took it was like who the [ __ ] took in
normals around us and then we shot
calling your own phone they wouldn't
pick up and we started driving and then
I was like this old man and it was
literally back it was where the old man
is and I'm like excuse me uh did you
take my phone
the yup he comes and he gave it to me
[Laughter]
yeah I think it was like either he was
like oh [ __ ] someone lost the phone and
he was gonna return it or something to
people yeah no [ __ ] he was like he was
like he was like I'm gonna get away with
this he saw he was like [ __ ] big asian
do this no there you go yes sorry sir no
no what no none of that
if you look different what do you have
given a better I was gonna take it to
the police station I shot a music video
one so we were shooting at a like a
train station and then back down for a
little bit it was nighttime and it's
like a long hallway and then like it was
nighttime the the backpack was there I
turned my back for a little bit he was
shooting over there we turned her around
and the backpacks gone and the only
person that was there was little old
homeless lady that was hobbling along
and she had a long skirt and I was just
like what the no there's no way cuz she
was like this so she put it in between
her legs I don't know you didn't [ __ ]
dude I was like hey ker bulb and then it
was in between her legs like a penguin
holding a bag so maybe they were like
excuse me map she goes
she was playing with because then he
didn't be saying I'll just leave her
alone I was like sure backpack it wasn't
anything too crazy but she had it I want
to say it was cuz she was the only one
she took it yeah I know that's a good
cause right baby put on the entire act
Lee and step stage do ya the long con
crazy so people leave you alone the
shoes weird I was like 11 o'clock at
night
yeah good time I know that's sad man I
know it's so like scary you could never
see I hate these stories cuz I'm like oh
I just want to trust people but then
well you can it's America I was like the
whole world is like this I also tie it
you met in Japan he never got his his
wallet back you didn't watch a pan I
fell out in the taxi taxi oh they never
mailed it Japan thought all that great
that honorable Widow you didn't get you
don't feel unsafe and things don't be
stolen from you like they're not
actually coming at you I know that like
in [ __ ] Europe like you have to cover
up and yeah or what if the guy felt like
he failed cuz he couldn't find you and
he killed himself
oh that's superb it could have reached
it honorable he just didn't use his
brain then at them you time travels in
the samurai James like samurai way taxi
cut his head off his best friend my
friend abou I was at Target the other
day and this like when we were leaving
this girl came up to us she was like 17
18 19 and she was like holding a blanket
and she was like hey can you guys give
me a ride home and I'll just like duh uh
what's goin on she goes um I just got
out of a psych ward or something and but
she was in regular clothes she's like I
just gonna have the psych ward and I
just need a ride back to Pomona I'm even
at work alone is is that far from us
thirty minutes okay and then she's like
and I'm like cross-faded and I can't my
phone I just killed somebody but I'm
safe yeah
drugs what I'd say like so we were like
really weird I was like um I'm not going
that direction but I can call the police
for you and they can like try to get you
home or cholera or something yeah and
then um and then she was like yeah but
that'll work and I'm like okay well if
she says that does she still here at the
police and he should be ok but then my
friend is also like hey why don't you
like try going into target it's nice and
safe in there and ask the employees to
call you or call the police to help you
and she's like okay y'all go in there I
don't know it sucks so like or if you
think about like homeless people right
so the spats are usually broken up into
threes and then so like the third of the
group is like people that are just down
and out and they're most likely they're
called like transition or whatever
they're most likely to get back on their
feet like those are just like people
that lost their homes or their jobs or
they're just kind of down and out but
then they want to get back into the
world right and then but but the but the
other third is the like that like like
people that have mental disabilities or
whatever and in their family just
abandon them or like just sad [ __ ] like
that you know it didn't they kind of get
left on in the streets but then the
other third are the other ones that just
don't want to be a part of society and
they just they get they get into drugs
and whatever and and so like I think the
two that need the help the most are the
ones that want to get back into the
world and the ones that have mental
disabilities where they just cannot work
or whatever and that's what sucks cuz
like that it's like day for them it's
they're safer like in jail or the asylum
than they are out in the street that's
true
but to me I'm just like damn dude that
sucks that we don't have any programs
that helps and we have the resources
it's just not being allocated properly
mm-hmm yeah that's it that's the crazy
part we got mad money but they also
there's no like foolproof plan right
it's always like any plan that you come
up with has so many flaws that affects
somebody else negatively seems to be
better than the plan they're doing now
it just seems to be just shifting
homeless people from town to town to
town until
the people the locals in that town line
we don't want these homeless people here
and then they just ship him to another
place I don't actually healthy yeah
there's that photo got caught sending
homeless people to Honolulu on one-way
tickets they would clean them up and
then they would just buy a one-way
ticket out of Detroit and then yeah
people were like I think the city of
Honolulu is suing Detroit for doing that
I think it's a problem also that it's a
it's a it's the way society is - it's
more like well me first don't care about
you like I don't care about these
homeless people it's me me me I don't
want it it's hell American yeah it's
kind of like yeah yeah but it's also
interesting that there's people like
this that are scamming people and
they're not necessarily homeless but
they're just they only see this as the
only way that they can make some sort of
living is by taking from others and that
just sucks yeah I think desperation is
what drives people a lot to crime like I
was like oh and also how they're raised
right because like sometimes crime is
normalized in certain families and
that's the way that they made money
because Society failed them right so
they have no opportunities and the way
that they can make mint money is by
basically like stealing or cheating the
system or cheating people right so if
you I think I always say this but the
best way to combat crime and terrorism
and all that [ __ ] is finding ways to
give opportunity to a community because
if people saw that like if they worked
hard and then they can be somebody and
they believe that they can do that they
would much rather do that and live in a
safe world then live a life of crime
like they don't people don't want to do
that it's just that's what they think
that they're capable of doing it doing
that which [ __ ] sucks
did she get her money back oh yeah so
venmo did put a stop on it it takes like
three days to cash out anyways so yeah
she's just like Oh Betty swag teracle
that's a lot of money
yeah hawkman I think you chose that
number moral of the story is my password
protect your venmo
[Music]